thank you
[Music]
all right this is a pretty pretty crazy
story and it's still
um in development so I really predict
we're going to come back to this one
later
there's a uh there's a strict father
raising his family in Iowa right just
imagine this life he lives in Iowa over
some Farmland he's got like a couple
daughters yeah white definitely uh good
call Jason and as the daughters are like
young they remembered that they would
have to like wheelbarrow a bunch of
things across the Farmland to a well but
like that was like their chore back to
the world you'd always say we're going
back to the well going back to the well
they would he'd put a bunch of stuff
they would all have to go and just dump
this stuff right in the well in the
world you know where this is going
that's the opposite it's humans it's
limbs
he chopped up bodies so now that that is
now that that father is dead the
daughter
um believes that they were transporting
human remains and then um so she like
she snitches
keep that to your old family police and
the police sent cadaver dogs to like
check if it's at all true
and it came back positive so now they're
doing a full excavation of the area and
they believe that the father could have
murdered a total count of 70 women oh yo
seven over decades and then the doctors
go to jail for being accomplices but
here's the thing the the daughter
daughter number one believes that that's
that that their father was a serial
killer yeah otter number two things
daughter number one is just [ __ ]
crazy no way but there's [ __ ] the
cadaver dog said they smelled some [ __ ]
how did they stumble upon the number 70.
they think the murders have happened in
a very like localized area it's not like
a big big town so like over the time 70
women have been maybe there's 70 cold
cases of like women that and most of
they said kind of similar most of the
deceased are probably sex workers so you
know when you kill sex workers like
about [ __ ] they're so [ __ ] up yeah
but in a small town if you kill 70 women
that's less women yeah you would think
it'd be like really obvious right
weren't they all at yeah
you could have more women yeah yeah even
not a little bit guy Jesus Christ yeah I
mean it's over several decades so who
knows like how long this was but also as
another twist turns out that in back in
2007 that same daughter tried to tell
the police that this was a thing and
they sent police to investigate and they
didn't find anything but turns out they
look in the wrong [ __ ] spot it was
just like look it sounds like my oven
thing this morning so they didn't know
when they when they went over to look at
the area they didn't know the well she
was talking about was not on their
actual property it's like over the price
she's stupid she's not giving them the
right GPS coordinates oh at first I was
split I was like man because you know
when the minute they come and excavate
your property you can't even live at
your own house that's so inconvenient
I'm like do I want to like inconvenience
myself or do I want to help people find
like residents like 70 people you know
but then I was like now the well is
across the border I don't care go
excavates my neighbor's house I'll help
with Justice now yeah it's not on my
problem because I guess it was more than
one well and then they and then there
was different areas so when you in 2007
when she tried to tell them she would
she didn't know exactly like what spots
that they were going to as kids why
would you want to contaminate your
drinking water well it's the neighbor's
drinking water it wasn't a working well
bodies yeah it was basically just a pit
but that's so stupid but it was also so
stupid that you dump it in a while
because if you if you go down to the
well you find a body yeah but I guess no
one but it might be really hard to go
down into the well it might be like a
crane and nobody living in Iowa there's
probably like 30 Acres of nothing oh and
by the way in 2007 when they did
investigate they did partially like
excavate the areas that she was talking
about they didn't find anything and it
cost them 300 Grand to do it oh it's
kind of a thing where they're not like
okay and the dad was the dad already
dead in 2007 no he wasn't and he didn't
kill his daughter then no yeah but then
the daughter always felt like he was
gonna kill them eventually but he never
did wow he died in 2017. and then the
the younger daughter's like man my
sister's been crazy this [ __ ] is nuts
yeah she go the other daughter's just
like no he was just a strict Dad but he
wasn't killing people like they have two
different opinions on it which is crazy
oh no so what's the evidence of the
older daughter then it's like just just
a well just not her memory she never
[ __ ] opened it up and been like
that's an arm Dad I'm just scared as
[ __ ] you know she remembers believing
even then that they were transporting
humans
apparently so maybe something tipped her
off did she have any sense did she have
any like specific details of like what
exactly they were transporting no she
didn't have any she didn't have any
specific like what it was like it might
have been just plastic wrapped stuff oh
it's like trash bags everything's inside
already like it was never like an actual
like exposed human
but there's no way you kill 70 women and
then the daughter doesn't know about it
one time yeah do what I mean the dab
might be really good at 70 times yeah
how many times have you seen your wife's
tampons
all the time
well she's not very good at home again
yeah she's not good at high dangles it
yeah prove it the mistletoe that's true
after me with Geo for what
about to be 15 years together I have
never heard her fart no that's how good
she is yeah never ever heard her fart
what is that you are or like what's
going on I don't know well one of us is
back but you smelled it but you don't
hear it ever never even smelled it
she would rather [ __ ] like have a
stomachache than to let it out in front
of me oh my God that's so nice
the [ __ ] whole Gracie Jiu Jitsu
manual and none of it yeah that's
pre-workout none of it ever came out
some people were good man oh man okay
that's true if you can hide that you can
add seven that changed Jason's mind he's
like yeah you're right it's really hard
I feel like that's harder than yeah 70
women yeah
yeah that's really hard holy [ __ ] oh
dude yeah so they're they're really
going to be looking into this now go to
the correct places because the the dog
the cadaver dogs found
um traces of human remains in four
places including the well oh so they
found something well they found traces
but they haven't found actual full
bodies yet they have to actually dig up
because that's again that's why you put
[ __ ] in a well because it's hard to get
to right you can't go down the well you
have to actually dig around the well and
just dig the yeah you can just like
Take the bucket I'm coming down no
is that an umbrella
is that kind of well where it's so big
that a person could like go yeah it's
one of those ones where probably as big
as the bucket oh my God and if you threw
a body down it's probably going down
like that's why they need to come up
with better drones and [ __ ] like throw a
Dalmatian that sniffs well in order in
order for them to really you know I
guess when you're gonna dig up dead
bodies you have to actually physically
acquire the you can't just like go down
look oh yeah they're there and then
that's the case yeah like you'd have to
like you gotta get a bone or something
identify the by the dentals and do all
the stuff you know that's cool it's a
lot of work it's gonna cost a lot but
yeah but they actually found it this
time you said 300 000 before but if you
just rent like a crane like this crane
and then just dig it yeah do I mean and
then just dig these guys are dumb huh it
comes to City money they love to [ __ ]
it's because they don't have a Taiwanese
man on the team that could do it for a
good price yeah yeah exactly that's true
they have to use the county people and
then they're gonna have meetings
yeah yeah it takes 12 meetings to get a
print out there yeah you gotta have
meetings man or else the Cradle work but
that is already suspicious like number
one I wouldn't have ever even thrown
trash down a well yeah but to do that
like 70 plus times and you know I mean
obviously more than 70 times because
they're not doing one whole body at a
time right it's probably like increments
they probably had to do this [ __ ]
wealth thing hundreds of times yeah yes
wouldn't that be crazy though to like be
doing this mundane chore your whole life
as a kid and then someday oh my God
Clicks in and you go those are bodies oh
[ __ ] like but why would you have the
kids join like kids are [ __ ] useless
well it's faster yeah they had to help
because you know moving bodies is is
hard work but Joe yesterday you were
talking about kids and Free Labor bruh
so you can't be flip-flopping like well
there are kids in their 20s
I've done them for 20 years yeah I wish
I [ __ ] wish yeah cause what what
purpose of like the purpose of a well is
to get water typically right so the weld
doesn't work why would you just be
throwing stuff down there anyway that's
the thing is most most Wells nowadays
are not used as well because we don't
need them maybe they're used to throw
dead bodies out they're used for the
weird thing though having a chore going
down to a well to throw things in it
yeah that's what I'm saying that is even
if it wasn't body it was just trash
they're literally yeah
places there are other places they would
go but then the world is the easiest
identity viable memory wise because it's
a [ __ ] well you know like it's easier
than longitude and latitude as a kid
even even if it's not bodies why do they
keep going through the well
they're not getting rich dad part right
like I can understand it's like your
your strict father is making you do
something it's like man I have to do
this chore and you're not thinking but
then
over a hundred times plus or whatever
going to like put like the math don't
add up in terms of like I wouldn't put
something down a well let's go to the
other daughter's mentality is like that
was just a chore to do like to for
discipline but we weren't getting rid of
dead bodies Sheriff but what what else
would it be if it's not dead that's what
I'm saying exactly who knows it could
have just been some pointless dirt to
like just to do something yeah yeah you
know what this reminds me of I can't
help like when you start when you teed
off the story I can't help but to think
of Colleen talking about washing rocks
and her strict dad we had a girl here
that was telling us that her dad would
make her wash rocks for no reason wash
them they were bones and the crazy thing
is her dad was a murderer oh how many
rocks